so what what I'd say is I'm first of all
I'm really sad and disappointed about
the disruption that has been caused so
many people's lives particularly at
Christmas time you know when it comes to
lesbians it's a difficult question of
setting public sector pay the government
has acted fairly and reasonably in
accepting all the recommendations of the
public sector pay review bodies that's
an independent process the government
has listened to and I think we all know
that the major economic challenge we all
face now is inflation it's inflation
that's eating into everyone's pay
packets is rising the cost of living and
I want to make sure that we reduce
inflation part of that is being
responsible when it comes to setting
public sector pay that's why we have an
independent process I know things are
difficult but it's right that there's an
independent body that makes
recommendations to the government and
the government accepted those that it
increased its offer matched all those
recommendations I think that's the
reasonable thing to do and in the long
term it's the right thing for the whole
country that we beat inflation